les juges sur une grande décision tu vas
te couper les cheveux
pourquoi il dit ça y est très bien avec
les cheveux moussu j'ai décidé de me
présenter à l'élection présidentielle
c'est une bonne décision - jeff mais tu
ton la pelouse d'abord il est 20 heures
voici les résultats de l'élection
présidentielle
jeff tuche élu avec 57 % des voix
je ne sais pas il nous a dit il faut que
j'aille au war aulas a fait pour une
bonne aide
qui sait quel ministre des maths face de
l'école de l'éducation nationale non le
ministre de l'école cela à la voix
non et amis de l'école dans le train de
faire le devoir de votre fille vous à
qui des ports sais c'est pas évident si
vous y arrivez pas comment voulez-vous
mais s'en sortent sains c'est quand même
car problèmes de programme